I know that you're a big Game of Thrones
fan you actually auditioned to be
Khaleesi I believe oh yeah okay so now
that back one way back when so now that
house of dragon is on social media would
love to see you in the Game of Thrones
wheelhouse somehow whether it's House of
dragon or another spin-off what's your
reaction to that would you want to be a
part of it yeah I mean sure but like
what I don't know how things like rumors
like that get started and people think
they're legitimate I think dreamcasting
is just so fun stream casting's fun yeah
I heard that it was like announced
though which is weirder you heard that
it was actually announced that you're
joining the game from someone with a
blue check I heard when I did my variety
interview for tonight and you're here to
confirm that you are not officially in
any Game of Thrones project I mean I've
never heard of such a thing the Marvel
world has such loyal fans The Game of
Thrones world has such Loyola fans does
that Intrigue you sure I mean anything
anything that's like worth telling
that's a good story that's Innovative
that's great great characters and and
yeah sure it's fun it's television and
movies it's dreamcasting it's just fun
let's manifest it Elizabeth Olsen in
Game of Thrones somehow when I'm Queen I
will create a new order
Kevin feige has said that we haven't
exactly Seen the Last of the Scarlet
Witch and you're good pal Catherine Han
she's about to go on a New Journey with
Agatha are there conversations about you
maybe popping up over on that spin-off I
mean no but I would love to I'd love to
pop up I mean yeah I love Catherine I
don't want to leave her side ever I'm so
grateful she's here tonight yeah going
to work with her looks like a blast yeah
she's a great she's a great fun I love
her when you guys are together do you
conspire about what could we do what
could that look like
um I mean not really but we do think
like gosh we just gotta do it again yeah
we just we women we really had a great
time making that show and and with Paul
and um it was really a special time and
so we would love to get the gang back
[Music]
okay
are you a little Starstruck of course I
am it's Hillary Clinton yeah big deal
yeah you're an honoree tonight
congratulations there are so many
incredible powerful women in the world
but who is the one that is motivating
you and inspiring you to to be your best
um honestly I the women that I'm here
tonight with Gail oberbonyl
um from great foundation and Debbie
tansman who runs the volunteer program
at Stewart house they are really
incredible women who have dedicated
their life to um to incredible work I'm
just overwhelmed right now because
Hillary Clinton's right behind me so I'm
I'm glad I have a script that's written
for me tonight
[Music]
foreign